számomra nagyon érdekes az hogy az ember
képes arra hogy az élet tragédiájával
szembenézzen hogy hogy képesek vagyunk a
legnehezebb pillanatban is felállni van
aki összeomlik van aki viszont feláll és
nem tudom megmondani mi a különbség a
kettő között ugyanaz az ember nem nem
lehet így kívülről kiszámolni hogy hogy
ha ebbe a kontextusb van akkor biztos
ezt fogja csinálni szőnyű helyzetekben
szörnyű kontextusban emberek csodálatos
módon képesek voltak felállni és a
legvégső v harcolni
ezek ez számomra is egy követendő
csodálatos példa amire nem hiszem hogy
képes vagyok és ugyanakkor sokkal jobb
helyzetben levő embereket ismertem én
személyesen akik akik összeroppantak a a
sokkal kisebb súly alatt